en este vídeo quiero hablar del
gradiente en el contexto de los
conjuntos de nivel así que digamos que
tenemos una función f que tiene dos
variables como entrada verdad y que la
función f simplemente haga el producto
de x con ye entonces para esta función
nosotros podríamos ver cuáles son sus
conjuntos de nivel verdad más o menos
por ejemplo aquí estaría el eje x aquí
podríamos pintar quizás más abajo más o
menos aquí podríamos pintar el eje de
verdad y podríamos mostrar cuáles son
las curvas de nivel
ahí lo tenemos entonces aquí por ejemplo
está el eje x el eje y muy bien y lo que
esto representa son los conjuntos en
donde la función toma un valor constante
por ejemplo si nos preguntamos cuál es
el conjunto en donde la función es igual
a 2 verdad entonces estaríamos pensando
en el conjunto en donde x porque sea
igual a 2 o bien si nosotros despejamos
podríamos decir que ya es igual a 2
entre x entonces esto quizás representa
a esta curva que tenemos aquí verdad de
hecho vamos a hacernos nuevamente
espacio para poder trabajar más con esto
con esta idea del gradiente y ahora si
nosotros queremos calcular el gradiente
de nuestra función tenemos el gradiente
de nuestra función esto resulta ser
ahora una función de dos variables
verdad que va a tener una salida de dos
dimensiones verdad y de hecho recordemos
como lo vimos en el vídeo anterior
el gradiente simplemente se calcula como
el vector que tiene la parcial de la
función f con respecto de x y la
derivada parcial de f con respecto de de
verdad y si tuviéramos más variables
tendríamos más coordenadas en este caso
así que cuál sería este este gradiente
para esta función particular bueno
cuando derivamos con respecto de x ya
resulta ser una constante verdad
entonces realmente simplemente
tendríamos que hacer la derivada de
nuestra función con respecto de x esto
es una constante y al derivar x nos
queda 1 así que simplemente obtenemos
aquí de verdad si ahora derivamos esto
con respecto del x es una constante y
nos queda x por la derivada de ye que es
así que este sería nuestro vector
gradiente y esto en realidad se puede
visualizar como un campo vectorial por
ejemplo si nos fuéramos al punto 2 1
digamos que aquí está el 1
aquí está el 2 y luego aquí está el 1
entonces nos vamos a un punto digamos
por aquí este sería el punto 2,1 y
nosotros sabemos que el gradiente de
esta función en ese punto particular
sería invertir las coordenadas verdad
entonces tendríamos que pintar el vector
2 verdad entonces para pintar esto
simplemente nos movemos 1 en la
dirección del eje x y luego subimos 2 en
la dirección del eje y y más o menos así
se vería nuestro vector 12 verdad
anclado en este punto que es la idea
justamente de los campos vectoriales así
que ahora podríamos mostrar el campo
vectorial vamos a mostrarlo y aquí sería
conveniente recordar que los colores nos
indican la longitud real de los vectores
que estamos pintando verdad porque si
los pintamos con su tamaño real pues
esto se vería muy enredado y no nos
permitiría ver absolutamente nada verdad
aquí los colores en rojo son vectores
que en realidad son muy muy largos
mientras que los vectores azules son
vectores que son realmente cortos verdad
así que algo que quizás hay que notar es
que cada vector digamos si un vector
cruza una curva de nivel en realidad ese
cruce lo hace de forma perpendicular a
la curva verdad por ejemplo podríamos
fijarnos
en este de aquí también podríamos
fijarnos en este de acá también
podríamos fijarnos en este otro de acá
esto ocurre en cualquier punto o digamos
en cualquier lugar donde el vector cruce
una curva de nivel entonces pensemos por
ahora por qué es que ocurre esto así que
vamos a borrar lo que tenemos del lado
derecho para darnos un espacio para
poder seguir trabajando
entonces borremos todo esto
todo esto
y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es tratar
de acercar digamos este punto vamos a
considerar este punto de aquí ok y vamos
a hacer un acercamiento a lo que está
ocurriendo por acá así que digamos vamos
a hacer vamos a acercar la imagen a lo
que está ocurriendo en ese cerca de ese
punto digamos aquí tenemos nuestro
nuestra lupa y por ejemplo aquí
tendremos nuestra curva de nivel pasando
por esta parte verdad más o menos es una
representación de esta curva de nivel y
digamos que es justo la curva de nivel
asociado al valor 2 verdad son los
puntos donde la función vale exactamente
2 muy bien entonces en realidad esta
curva debería irse pareciendo cada vez
más a una línea recta a medida que
hacemos un acercamiento más y más y más
profundo verdad entonces aquí tenemos
nuestro punto que hemos seleccionado
verdad y cuando queremos interpretar el
vector gradiente como vimos en el vídeo
anterior
este apunta siempre en la dirección del
ascenso más pronunciado así que si
imaginamos todos los posibles vectores
que pueden estar anclados a este punto
todos estos todos estos vectores verdad
entonces la pregunta es en qué dirección
tenemos que movernos para incrementar el
valor de la función f lo más rápido
posible y existen dos formas en las que
podemos ver esto la primera forma es
digamos ver en qué dirección aumenta
digamos en la componente xy en la
componente jet lo más rápido posible la
segunda forma que podríamos considerar
es digamos pensar en otra curva de nivel
que hacemos en otra curva de nivel
quizás debería debería borrar estos
vectores
a borrar estos vectores amarillos de
aquí
sus vectores amarillos y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es considerar otra curva
de nivel ligeramente cercana a esta que
ya teníamos aquí y quizás mi dibujo no
es del todo preciso pero espero que se
entienda la idea así que digamos que
esta es la curva de nivel asociada al
valor 2.1 y en realidad estas dos curvas
deberían parecer digamos como paralelas
verdad no difieren mucho la una de la
otra entonces ahora ahora pensemos
digamos a partir de este mismo punto en
todos los vectores que pueden moverse de
este valor 2 al 2.1 entonces podríamos
pensar quizás en este vector quizás en
este otro vector quizás otro un poco más
alejado o también podríamos pensar en
este vector verdad ahora decidir cuál es
la dirección del ascenso más pronunciado
digamos la forma más rápida de movernos
a esta otra curva de nivel es
equivalente a pensar digamos en elegir
el vector que tenga una distancia menor
verdad y en realidad no es
y convencerse de que
hay que elegir justamente la dirección
que es perpendicular a esta curva verdad
esta dirección perpendicular es la que
nos da una digamos una distancia menor
verdad así que debido a esta
interpretación del gradiente es
consecuencia que cuando vemos las curvas
de nivel verdad el gradiente siempre es
perpendicular a estas curvas de nivel
siempre va a hacer que sea perpendicular
a cada línea pues trata de acercarse a
las otras líneas tan rápido como sea
posible y esta es una interpretación muy
útil en algunos contextos siempre el
gradiente será perpendicular a las
curvas de nivel nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo